all of these kids but I might nervous
him [ __ ] nervous like if a cat was
big enough it absolutely would eat you I
am beyond excited to meet a kitten they
don't bother me I don't bother them
don't like cats I might be allergic to
cats I know that I'm allergic to cats so
I'm gonna go visit the incubator where
the cats are hatched here we go it's a
little image a tune and two of one
all night
they're doing it there are three small
children cats child cats
I don't like this one we're getting more
of these level little love loves of joy
do you need my help I'm feeling
feelings of what I can only describe
this maternal protection reminds me of
Stallone and cliphair
[Music]
I feel like a mommy I take back all the
really mean things I said about cats
am i a changed man yes it could have
been worse I met I was a little
skeptical at first
this is it's pretty adorable I don't
know I mean I could see myself getting a
little kitten like this they're pretty
cute
I felt something this has been a mind
changing experience for me
I really have changed my mind about cats
and you should adopt one I'll be fine I
feel like if you like raise them and
those it's like love you forever like
look at this little guy you just this
says the tool for the job you must learn
to hunt little ones survive No